David Boder: [In German] Sagen Sie mir, was ist Ihr Namen?
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish] רייזל ראסעט.
David Boder: [In German] Was ist die Namen?
David Boder: [In German] Raisel?
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish] ראסעט.
David Boder: [In German] Roset?
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish] יא.
David Boder: [In German] War das Ihr Namen in Poland auch? Gesprechen...[unklar; Boder lacht nervös].
David Boder: [In German] Das war Ihr Namen. Un wie alt sind Sie, Frau Rose?
Raisel Roset: Schon fünfzig Jahre alt.
David Boder: Sind Sie fünfzig Jahre alt.
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish] יא.
David Boder: [In German] Sind Sie verheiratet?
David Boder: [In German] Eh, wo ist Ihr Mann?
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish] ער איז געוועזן אין אקופירטן [ראם?] פון פוילן, און ווען ס’איז אויסגעשאסן די דייטש-רוסישע קריג, פון. דאן אום, האב איך שוין פון אים קיין [אכט?] נישט. פון קיעוו, ליידער, [אומקלאר?] אז ער איז געפאלן.
David Boder: [In German/Yiddish] Gefallen?
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish] ער איז אומגעקומען. מ’אט אים אומגעבראכט.
David Boder: [In German/Yiddish] Wer?
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish] שטילערהייט] איך ווייס נישט].
David Boder: [In German] So, wie haben Sie das...[unklar]?
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish] דאס האב איך געהערט. דאס האט מיר איין קוזינע געשריבן פון פוילן, אז ער איז אין קרעמענעץ אומגעבראכט געווארן.
David Boder: [In German] Uh huh. Sie haben eine Kusine in Poland?
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish] מיין מאנס א קוזינע.
David Boder: [In German] In Russisch-Poland oder in Freien-Poland?
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish] אין פרייען פוילן.
David Boder: [In German/Yiddish] Freien Poland. Now, sagen Sie mir, wen sind Sie...sind die דייטשן gekomm...Wie haben Sie gelebt?
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish] אין זאמאשטש.
David Boder: [In German] Wie?
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish] לובלינער קרייז-זאמאשטש, לובלינער קרייז.
David Boder: [In German/Yiddish] Lubliner Kreis? Und das was Poland?
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish] יא.
David Boder: [In German/Yiddish] Un wer sind dortn אריינגעקאמען—die Russians—die Russen?
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish] די דייטשן.
David Boder: [In German/Yiddish] די דייטשן? Nu, erzähl mir.
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish]זיי זענען געווען...[אומקלאר?] טאגע, די דייטשן זענען אריינגעקומען דעם 6טן ווזשעשין. און.... [אומקלאר?] טאגע, האבן זיי פארלאסט זאמאשטש, און ס’זענען געקומען די רוסן.
David Boder: Ah ha.
Raisel Roset: דאן איז מיין מאן אוועק מיט זיי אויך...[אומקלאר?] פון א ציוניסטישער ארגאניזאציע, און די זענען געווען דער ערשטע געשיקט געווארן די קאנצענטראציע לאגערן. איז ער אוועק קיין דובנאוו.
Raisel Roset: און אכער, קיין קרעמענעץ.
David Boder: Uh huh.
Raisel Roset: די גאנצע צייט האב איך באקאמען [באקומען] פון אים בריף, אבער אכער, ווען ס’איז אויסגעבראכן די רוסיש-דייטש קריג, האט זיך די קארעספאנדענץ איבערגעריסן. איך האב א ספעציעלן שליח צו אים געשיקט, און דער, האט מיך [אומקלאר?] פון דעם ידיעה פון מיין איידעם, האט ער מיך אפגענארט אז מיין מאן איז קיין רוסלאנד געפארן, אויף טיף רוסלאנד.
David Boder: Yeah.
Raisel Roset: איך בין געווען בארויקט, און דאן האט זיך אנגעהויבן אונדזערע טענהן אין פוילן.
David Boder: [In German/Yiddish] So, wer גלויבן Sie, hat dem Mann umgebracht?
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish] איך ווייס דאס נאך נישט.
David Boder: [In German/Yiddish] Die דייטשן oder die [Russen]?
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish] איך ווייס דאס נאך נישט. איך האב דאס נאך נישט דערפארן.
David Boder: Uh huh.
Raisel Roset: פאר מע’ זאגט מיר נאך נישט דעם גאנצן אמת.
Raisel Roset: און דאן האט זיך אנגעהויבן דעם טערמין [אומקלאר?] פון אויסזידלען יידן.
David Boder: די דייטשן...
Raisel Roset: יא, די [משיעור?] אויס יודען. האט מען געמאכט אין דער שטאט זאמאשטש אין גענצן [גאנצן] יודענריין.
David Boder: Yeah.
Raisel Roset: און אלע זאמאשטשער איינוווינער האט מען געשיקט אין א קליינעם שטעטל, 02 קילאמעטער פון זאמאשטש קיין איזביצא [?]. דארט, האט זיך ווידער אנגעפאנגען דאס זעלבע. איין [אומקלאר?] יידן האט געפארט נאך דער צווייטער. אין איינעם טאג האבן מיר געזען אז אונדזער פרעזעז פון יודענראט איז אנטלאפן. דאן, האבן מיר געווייסט [געוווסט] אז עס קומט פון דעם, צו דעם נישט גוטע זאך.
David Boder: [In English] Yes.
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish] און דאן, דער וואס האט געהאט מעגלעכקייטן, האט זיך געראטעוועט. איז פארשטענדלעך. און איך, אין דער האפענונג אז מיין מאן איז אין רוסלאנד, האב איך באשאפט ארישע פאפירן.
David Boder: [In German] Was für Papiern?
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish] ארישע.
David Boder: [In German/Yiddish] Arische Papieren?
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish] און כ’בין אנטלאפן.
David Boder: Aha.
Raisel Roset: איך בין אנטלאפן צו א באקאנטע, כלומרישע פאמיליע, און דארט בין איך געוועזן 6 וואכן. און אכער, האבן זיי מיר שוין נישט געוואלט האלטן, ווייל ס’אט זיי אויך געדראט דויטשן [דייטשן] ווען מע’ טרעפט מיך ביי זיי. האב איך געמוזט נעמען מיין פעקל און ווייטער וואנדערן. בין איך געפארן קיין טשענסטאכאוו. אין טשענסטאכאוו בין איך געוועזן א פאר וואכן, זיך ארומגעדרייט יעדן טאג, נישט גענעכטיקט, אויף קעלט, געמוזט ארומגיין גאנצע טעג אויף די גאס, געווען שווער פאר מיר צו געפינען א וווינונג, און דאן האב איך געזען אז ס’איז קיין פלאן נישט פאר מיר אויכעט, און קריק אריין אין דעם יודענלאגער.
David Boder: Uh huh.
Raisel Roset: אין געטא - צוריק אין געטא - אין יידישן געטא.
David Boder: Yeah.
Raisel Roset: אין יידישן געטא, האט זיך אנגעהויבן ווידער די אייגענע פיין. ווייטער דעפארטאציעס, און כ’אב ז...- מיך האב זיך פארשריבן צו ארבעטן אין אן אמוניציע פאבריק. און דארט האב איך געארבעט 5 מאנאט.
David Boder: Uh huh.
Raisel Roset: און אכער, בין איך געווער [געוואר] געווארן אז ס’וועט זיין א סעלעקציע - די עלטערעס [?] ‘וועט מען זעלבספארשטענדלעך אוועקשיקן אין די גאז-קאמערן, און די יינגערע וועט מען לאזן. און איך, אלס עלטערע פרוי, האב פארשטאנען אז ס’קומט דער סוף. האב איך ווייטער אנגעהויבן זוכן עצות [?] ווי זיך צו ראטעווען. איך האב זיך ווידער פארשרייבט - נאך א מאל ארישע פאפירן - און כ’בין אנטלאפן פון טשענסטאכאוו. פון דען בין איך אויף דער פוילישער זייט אלס אריאן דעפארטירט געווארן ק’[יין] דייטשלאנד אויף ארבעט. דא...
David Boder: [In German] Why haben Sie deportiert die Aryen?
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish] די דייטשן?
David Boder: Ja.
Raisel Roset: אלס אריאן האבן זיי מיך דעפארטירט ק’[יין] דייטשלאנד אויף ארבעט.
David Boder: א, זיי האבן געדאכט אז זי זינט א דייטשין?
Raisel Roset: א נישט באגערן[?]!
David Boder: [In German] Aha, als Polin.
Raisel Roset: Yeah.
David Boder: [In Yiddish] נו?
Raisel Roset: געקומען קיין דויטשלאנד [דייטשלאנד], האט מען שוין דארט געשיקט קיין לאטערינגען.
David Boder: Uh huh.
Raisel Roset: דארט, האבן זיי מיך באשטימט איך וויל גיין ארבעטן אויף א פירם.
David Boder: אויף א פעלד?
Raisel Roset: אויף א פירמע.
David Boder: Uh huh.
Raisel Roset: און דארט האב איך אפגעארבעט 02 מאנאט, א שווערע קאטאר[גע].
David Boder: [In German] Was keine Arbet was?
Raisel Roset: Erdarbeit.
David Boder: Erdarbeit?
David Boder: [In Yiddish] לאנקע ארבייט?
Raisel Roset: לאנקע ארבייט, גארטן ארבייט...
David Boder: Uh huh.
Raisel Roset: אין שטוב, איבער א...[אומקלאר?]
David Boder: [In German/Yiddish] Vollzeit haben Sie gearbet als a Frau in a Haus?
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish] א הויפטפרוי אין גארטן, אין פעלד, איבעראל האב איך געארבעט.
David Boder: יא, איר האט געארבעט מיט דער פאמיליע?
Raisel Roset: מיט נאך מענטשן. ס’איז געוועזן נאך דארט; ס’איז געווען א רוסן מיידל, א דעפארטירטע; ס’איז געוועזן צוויי קריגס-געפאנגענע, און מיט די צוזאמען, האב איך געארבעט 02 מאנאט - זייער, זייער שווער.
David Boder: אנטשולדיק מיר, פאר וועמען האבן זי געארבעט?
Raisel Roset: פאר דעם פירמער.
David Boder: פאר דעם פירמער?
Raisel Roset: א דויטשע פירמער.
David Boder: Uh huh. Yeah.
Raisel Roset: און אכער, זענען...
David Boder: [In German/Yiddish] Haben Sie gut genumen zu Ihnen...[unklar]?
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish] איינער יא, זי, זייער שלעכט.
David Boder: . . . [?אומקלאר]
Raisel Roset: ס’אט מיר...[אומקלאר?] געפעלט אויך. איך האב א סך מאל געהונגערט. זי איז זייער א שלעכטע פרוי געווען.
David Boder: און ער איז?
Raisel Roset: ער, ניט.
David Boder: [In English] Alright.
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish] און דאן, נאך 02 מאנאט שווערע ארבעט, אין די געגנט [וואס איז] אקופירט געווארן פון די אמעריקאנער, און די האבן מיך באפרייט.
David Boder: נאך 02 מאנאט?
Raisel Roset: נאך 02 מאנאט ארבעט.
David Boder: Uh huh.
Raisel Roset: און די האבן מיך באפרייט און האבן מיך געשיקט ק’[יין] פאריז.
David Boder: [In German] Wie?
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish] קיין פראנקרייך. זיי האבן מיך געשיקט נאך פראנקרייך.
David Boder: [In German] Sie haben...[unklar?] geschriben?
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish] יא.
David Boder: [In German] Warum?
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish] איך האב זיי געבעטן.
David Boder: Oh.
Raisel Roset: איך וויל נאך פראנקרייך פארן; איך האב מורא ווידער זיין ביי די דייטשן ארבעטן ביי זיי, און בין איך אוועקגעשיקט נאך פראנקרייך.
Raisel Roset: און דא, בין איך ערשט אריין אין מיין גרויסן אומגליק.
David Boder: . . . [?אומקלאר]
Raisel Roset: כ’בין...[אומקלאר?] פון מיין גאנצע פאמיליע. פון א צו-הויכע פאמיליע, בין איך איינע געבליבן. און די שוועסטער און ברידער און אלץ. און לעצטנס בין איך געוואר אז אויך מיין מאן איז אומגעבראכט געווארן, ווי איך האב געזאגט.
David Boder: [In German] Uh huh. Now, sagen Sie mir Mrs. Roset, was war Ihr Manns Beschäftigung before...
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish] ער האט געהאט א מאנופאקטור געשעפט.
David Boder: [In German] Wo?
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish] אין זאמאשטש.
David Boder: אין זאמאשטש?
Raisel Roset: יא.
David Boder: [In German] Und, Sie sagen mir warum diese zionistische...
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish] פרעזידענט פון דער ציוניסטישער ארגאניזאציע אין זאמאשטש.
David Boder: [In German] Alright. Haben Sie gehabt Kinder?
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish] ניין.
David Boder: [In German] Sie haben die kinderlos?
Raisel Roset: Kinderlos—ja.
David Boder: Haben Sie Brüder oder Schwestern?
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish] צוויי ברידער, דריי שוועסטער מיט מענער, פרויען, קינדער, אלעס איז אומגעבראכט געווארן פון די דייטשן.
David Boder: [In German] Eh, waren Sie im Konzentrationslager?
Raisel Roset: Ich sag Dir...
David Boder: Nein.
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish/German] איך וואר אין אן ארבעטס-לאגער אין טשענסטאכאוו.
David Boder: . . . [?אומקלאר]
Raisel Roset: און פון דארט בין איך אנטלאפן, יא.
David Boder: [In German/Yiddish] Uh huh. Was war der Arbetslager im Czestochow[a]? Erzähl mir wegen...[unklar?] dem.
Raisel Roset: Das war ein Lager das...[unklar?]
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish] ווען מ’אט געמאכט די אקציע אין טשענסטאכאוו, האט מען איבערגעלאזט פון 000,05 יידן, א משיעור 000,1.
David Boder: און וואס מיט די איבעריקע איז געווען?
Raisel Roset: די איבעריקע האט מען געשיקט אין די קרעמאטאריעס און די גאז-קאמערן. און פון די 000,4, האט מען אפגענומען א קליין שטח פון די שטאט, א פאר הינטערגאסן; דארט האט מען אונדז ארומגעצויגן מיט שטעכעדיקע דראט, און דארט האבן מיר געוווינט. פון דאן...[אומקלאר?] די איינוווינער זענען געווען צעטיילט צו ארבעטן אין די פאבריקן.
David Boder: [In German/Yiddish] Oh. Nu. In was für a Fabriken haben Sie gearbeitet?
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish] ס’אבן געארבייט [געארבעט] אין - ביי ראביטשס [?] פאבריק...[אומקלאר?] פאבריק, אין דער פאבריק האסאג.
David Boder: [In German] Wo?
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish] האסאג, אן אמוניציע פאבריק.
David Boder: [In German] Oh. Sag mir [?], far Robyczs [?] Fabrik...
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish] פאר ראביטשס פאבריק.
David Boder: [In German] Warum...[unklar]...Robycz...[unklar]?
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish] פאר אלע פאבריקן זענען אונטערגעארדערט [?] געווארן אויף אמוניציע פאבריקן, זעלבפארשטענדלעך....
David Boder: [In German] Yeah. Und dort...
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish] און דארט האבן די יידן געארבעט. און אכער, ס’איז פארגעקומען סעלעקציעס און ס’איז פארגעקומען דעפארטאציעס. די עלטערע האט מען באשיסט; יינגערע, האט מען - פון - ס’אט זיך געראטעוועט די וואס האבן געוואלט - זעלבפארשטענדלעך.
David Boder: [In German/Yiddish] Ja. Sagen Sie, in diesen...[unklar/unclear?]. Sie haben gearbet in die Fabriken; wo haben Sie געשלאפן bei Nacht?
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish] אין דער פרי האט מען געדארפן זיין אין דער פאבריק. אונדז ‘אב...6 - 7
David Boder: [In English] Yeah.
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish] און דאס איז געווען א פאר קילאמעטער, האט מען - 6 אין דער פרי האבן זיך געעפנט די טויערן פונעם געטא - פון ארבייטס [ארבעטס]-לאגער. מ’אט ארויסגעלאזט די אלע ארבעטערס. זענען געגאנגען צו...[אומקלאר?] ארבעטן. זיבן פאר נאכט, איז מען צוריקגעקומען אהיים קיין - אין דעם לאגער, און דארט האט יעדער זיך געהאט רוים, מקום...[אומקלאר?].
David Boder: [In German] Das was?
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish] דאס מקום...[אומקלאר?] דארט האט מען געוווינט.
David Boder: [In German] Uh huh. Nu, sagt mir dis [this?]: Wo hat me gegessen?
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish] געגעסן האט מען אין דער פאבריק.
David Boder: אין - אם מארגן און אין...?
Raisel Roset: אם מארגן, אין מיטאג, אין...
David Boder: דארטן האט מען נישט געצאלט עפעס געלט פאר דער ארבעט...?
Raisel Roset: איך זאג - דארטן נישט - איך זאג דיר - דאן מ’אט נאר געגעבן עסן.
David Boder: נו, ווען מען האט ניט געהאט עפעס - זייף, ציגארעטן, אזעלכע זאכן?
Raisel Roset: ניין.
David Boder: ניין.
Raisel Roset: . . . ?]]’אט מען...[אומקלאר?] גארנישט געהאט
David Boder: האבן די יידן געהאט מנינים - זייער שול - אין געטא?
Raisel Roset: וואו, אין געטא? נא.
David Boder: [In English] No?
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish] ניין.
David Boder: ניין - מ’אט זיי נישט דערלייבט?
Raisel Roset: [In German/Yiddish] Nein, nein. Dort nisht. Dos war ein Arbeitslager.
David Boder: [In Yiddish/German] און אויך געארבעט שבת און זאנטיג?
Raisel Roset: זעלבספארשטענדלעך, זעלבספארשטענדלעך.
David Boder: [In German] Uh huh. Nu, haben Sie Verwanden [Verwandte] hier in Paris?
Raisel Roset: Hier hab ich niemand.
David Boder: Hier haben Sie niemand. So, Sie haben gross...
David Boder: [In Yiddish]...געפרעג - געבעטן די אמעריקאנערס, זיי זאלן צופירן
Raisel Roset: איך האב געהערט אז אין פאריז איז שוין דא יידן.
David Boder: Aha.
Raisel Roset: דעריבער, האב איך געבעטן אז מע’ זאל מיך שיקן ק’[יין] פאריז. און ק’[יין] פאריז בין איך געקומען אלס אריאן. און דא האב איך זיך ערשט געווענדט צו דער - א יידישע געזעלשאפט, און כ’אב אויסגעגעבן אז איך בין א יידיש קינד.
David Boder: [In German/Yiddish] Sagen Sie mir, wie haben Sie...[unklar?] Sie sind gewesen als an Aryan? Un die ganze Zeit in Lagers sind Sie gewesen als an Aryan?
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish/German] אין ארבייטס-לאגער בין איך געוועזן א יידינען. ווען...[אומקלאר?]
David Boder: [In German]...[unklar?] Bei die Farmeren?
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish] ביי די פארמערס, אן אריאן - זעלבספארשטענדלעך.
David Boder: ?האבן זי געצווונגען, אדער גע...[אומקלאר?] זאלן גיין אין קירך און זא ווייטער
Raisel Roset: יא, איך בין געגאנגען אייניגע מאל...
David Boder: ?צו א קאטאלישן
Raisel Roset: יא.
David Boder: [In German/Yiddish] Und wen Sie haben...sagen Sie mir, hat Mann die Polische ähnlich gehandelt wie die יידן?
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish] א, ניין. די פאלען האט מען פארשיקט דא אויף ארבעט, און יידן האט מען אומגעבראכט - גאנץ אנדערש. יידן האט מען דעפארטירט אין די גאז-קאמערן, אדער אין די קרעמאטאריען. און די פאלען - ווען מ’אט דעפארטירט, האט מען דעפארטירט ק’[יין] דייטשלאנד אויף ארבעט. דער עיקר וואס פירט זיך, האב איך געזען די ארישע פאפירן, אז מע’ זאל מיך נישט אוועקשיקן צו...
David Boder: [In German] Wer hat Ihnen gegeben die arische Papieren?
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish] פאר געלט.
David Boder: פאר געלט? Uh huh.
Raisel Roset: ס’איז געמאכט געווארן.
David Boder: [In German/Yiddish] Uh huh. Un den sind Sie gekommen nach Paris un jetzt hobn Sie gekommen zu wemen?
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish/German] Hier [?].
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish/French] איך זאג דיר [?], איך בין געקומען אין מיין פראנצויזישן אדינ...[אומקלאר?], און פון דארט, האב איך מיך אפגעגעבן אין פוילישן קאנסולאט, און דארט האב איך דערציילט אז איך בין א יידין, און געבעטן זיי זאלן מיר געבן אן אדרעס פון א יידישע געזעלשאפט, ווייל איך קום זיך אין...[אומקלאר?] זי איז געקומען מיר געגעבן, און דאן בין איך געווען אויף...[אומקלאר?] Boulevard d’Italien...
David Boder: [In German] Das war der Gesellschaft?
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish] יא. און די יידישע געזעלשאפט, און די האבן מיך אריינגעגעבן אויף א פאבניצע [?] סעקרעטארן. דארט איז געוועזן א הויז פון דעפארטירטע, און דארטן איז געוועזן מיין לענגערע צייט.
David Boder: [In German/Yiddish] Moment. Un den, wu wohnen Sie jetzt?
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish/English] יעצט...און אכער אין beginning [?] איז געווארן...[אומקלאר?] הויז, בין איך געגאנגען וווינען אויף מעץ...[אומקלאר?]
David Boder: [In German] Das Ort...[unklar?]
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish] און דארט איז ווו איך וווין ביזן היינטיגן טאג.
David Boder: [In German] Und was ist das? A private...?
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish] יעצט איז דאס - ניין. דאס איז אויך געוועזן א דעפארטירטן הויז, און אכער האט עס איבערגענומען דער קאנסיסטואר, ווייל דארט איז א סעמינאר - א ראבינער סעמינאר.
David Boder: Uh huh.
Raisel Roset: און קעגן מיך, האט מיך געבעטן אז מ’זאל מיך געבן ארבייט [ארבעט], און איך בין געבליבן דארטן וווינען.
David Boder: אין וואס ארבעטן זי דארט?
Raisel Roset: אלס קיך.
David Boder: [In German/Yiddish] Sie arbetn als Kich un Sie kochen dort—und Sie kommen jeden Abend?
Raisel Roset: In hier, am Abend.לערן איך זיך א פאך .
David Boder: Das mit die ORT.
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish] .יא
David Boder: [In German/Yiddish] Und וואס lernen Sie hier?
Raisel Roset: Hier? גארסעטן.
David Boder: [In German/Yiddish] גארסעטן. Wann Sie haben es gelernt, was wollen Sie tun?
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish] איך האב זיך דאך פארשריבן, שוין מיט א יאר צוריק - פארן נאך פאלעסטינע.
David Boder: [In German/Yiddish] Sie haben Sich verschriben צ’ פארן נאך פאלע...
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish] יא, שוין העכער ווי א יאר, איך האב זיך פארשריבן.
David Boder: [In German/Yiddish] Wemen haben Sie in Palestina?
Raisel Roset: Hab ich eine Kusin.
David Boder: Haben Sie geschriben zu Ihr?
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish] יא.
David Boder: [In German/Yiddish] זאגט Sie das Sie sollen kommen?
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish] א, זיכער.
David Boder: זאל דאס דאך זיין גוט. - נו, מיט אירע ערפארונגען - לאנדס-ארבייט
Raisel Roset: יא, איך וואלט דאס גערן געמאכט, אבער איך ווארט נאך אלץ און איך האב קיינע Erlaubnis פארן.
David Boder: א, יעצט [איצט] וועט עס באלד קאמען [קומען] .
David Boder: [In German] Eh, ob Sie konnen mir ein Gefallen tun...Ich bin Professor un ich studier diese Sachen. Sehen Sie das Bild? Was denken Sie ist dis [this]? Bild, die...[unklar?]
Raisel Roset: Was es gibt?
David Boder: Ja, was es meint. Wer denken Sie is es oder kann es sein?
Raisel Roset: Eine Mutter vielleicht was hat ihre Kinder verloren.
David Boder: A Mutter was hat gehat viele Kinder...Un was ist dis [this]?
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish/German] דאס איז איין יונגער קינד.
David Boder: Ja, un was denken Sie is hier?
Raisel Roset: Er denkt פון einer Melodie.
David Boder: Hmm...Un dis [this]?
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish] .דאס איז איין שטערבענדער [שטארבנדיקער]
David Boder: [In German] Ja...
Raisel Roset: [In Yiddish] דער...מאן בענטשט אים.
David Boder: Uh huh...און דאס?
Raisel Roset: דא אנטלויפט מען פון וואו, אנטלויפט מען פון וואו...
David Boder: [In German/Yiddish] Uh huh. Un dis [this]?
Raisel Roset: Uh, דאס איז das ausgeträumte Land פון עכט...